we got ready to go to bed and I was like
I'm and shouldn't get up and go to the
bathroom and I stand up and push my
water breaks okay we have four CPAP
apparatuses for delivery room dr. Minton
wanted to take the babies right away he
said with water breaking we start to
risk infection there are already
preemies for baby simultaneously at 29
weeks gestation 11 weeks premature every
risk that we have quadrupled yeah CBC
and a blood culture we had about 22
people who are in the adjacent
resuscitation room baby has a team of
four a nurse a respiratory therapist
another nurse to record a neonatologist
or a nurse practitioner so altogether 37
people in on the delivery look like
madness I'm thinking okay I'm sure it's
gonna be like an hour - I've got some
time to cope with this and before I'm
even pulling my blankets up there
unlocking the wheels and willing me down
the hall
I was scared I've spent the last however
many months trying to stay pregnant and
now it's just like it's time
you